Thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for underwriting this special two-part series about the power of sound to affect and influence our health and well-being. The Robert Wood Johnson Foundation is working alongside others to build a culture of health for everyone in America. Learn more about them at rwjf.org. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Sound can have serious impacts on our health and well-being. And ever since people moved into cities, we have been exposed to an unhealthy amount of noise,
感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会资助这个特别的两集系列节目，探讨声音影响和改变我们健康与福祉的力量。罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会正与各方合作，为美国所有人构建一种健康文化。请访问 rwjf.org 了解更多信息。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。声音会对我们的健康和福祉产生严重影响。自从人们搬进城市以来，我们就一直暴露在不健康的噪音环境中，
cars, power lines, and the constant ding of our devices. We live in a very noisy world. And most of the noises we hear aren't designed to work together. This is the second part of our special series on sound and health supported by the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation. We're taking a look at how a more intentional approach to sound can help us live better, healthier lives.
汽车、高压线，以及我们的电子设备不断的哔哔声。我们生活在一个非常吵闹的世界里。而且我们听到的大多数声音都不是为了协同工作而设计的。这是我们关于声音与健康的特别系列的第二部分，由罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会支持。我们将探讨如何以更有意图的方式对待声音，从而帮助我们过上更好、更健康的生活。
And there's no better place to think about health than hospitals. Joe Slesinger is an anesthesiologist at Vendorbilt Medical Center. He spends a lot of his time in the operating room. The operating room is an interesting space because we think of it, it's like my cockpit, if you will, and anesthesiology is related a lot to aviation. We are a culture of safety. We have safety checklists, just like pilots do.
要思考健康，没有比医院更好的地方了。乔·斯莱辛格是范德堡医学中心的一名麻醉医师。他的大部分时间都在手术室里度过。手术室是一个有趣的空间，因为我们认为它就像我的驾驶舱（如果你愿意这么说的话），而且麻醉学与航空业有很多相通之处。我们是一个崇尚安全的文化。我们有安全检查清单，就像飞行员一样。
We think of takeoff and landing, just like pilots do. We think of take-off in landing, just like putting a patient to sleep and waking them up. In fact, when we wake someone up from anesthesia, we call it landing the plane. Landing the plane takes focus, but Joe doesn't work in silence. It might come as a surprise, but in the OR, there's music playing all the time. There's great data that shows that music improves surgical efficiency, which can translate to an economic benefit, and music subjectively makes us feel good. And if you're working long hours
我们像飞行员一样思考起飞和降落。我们把让患者入睡和唤醒他们比作起飞和降落。事实上，当我们把某人从麻醉中唤醒时，我们称之为“飞机着陆”。飞机着陆需要集中注意力，但乔并不是在寂静中工作。这可能会让人感到意外，但在手术室里，音乐一直在播放。有大量数据表明，音乐可以提高手术效率，这可以转化为经济效益，而且音乐在主观上能让我们感觉良好。如果你长时间工作
doing difficult cases in the operating room, if you can improve mood, certainly there's benefit. But who chooses the music is usually the surgeon. And if the surgeon's excited the surgery is over and the music volume gets cranked up, it's really hard for us to be delicate and intentional and artful and elegant about our anesthetic. Joe remembers one surgery where music was playing
在手术室里处理棘手的病例，如果你能改善情绪，肯定是有好处的。但音乐通常由外科医生来选择。如果外科医生因为手术结束而兴奋，把音乐音量开得很大，我们就很难对麻醉保持细腻、有意识、巧妙和优雅。乔记得有一次手术，当时正放着音乐，
and then all of a sudden, the patient's vital signs started to crash. And so now my alarms are going off the music volume is high. The surgeon and I are having to raise our voices and almost yell at each other to communicate, not because we're mad at each other, but just to understand each other. So Joan, his researchers, are trying to figure out how to get the benefits of music in the
然后突然间，病人的生命体征开始崩溃。所以现在我的警报器在响，音乐音量很大。我和外科医生不得不提高嗓门，几乎冲对方大喊来沟通，不是因为我们生对方的气，只是为了能听懂对方说话。因此，乔和他的研究人员正试图找出如何在
OR without the risk of hearing we built this city on rock and roll while someone is having a heart attack. I'm working with another anesthesiologist on a device which is called the Canary Box. The Canary Box has two levels of alarm, a warning zone and a danger zone. When the alarm is in the warning zone, it has the music volume.
手术室里获得音乐的好处，同时又没有在有人心脏病发作时放着“我们在这座摇滚之城上建立了一切”的风险。我正与另一位麻醉医师合作开发一种名为“金丝雀盒子”的设备。金丝雀盒子有两个级别的警报：警戒区和危险区。当警报处于警戒区时，它会调低音乐音量。
And when the alarm is in the danger zone, it turns the music volume. And when the alarm is in the danger zone, it turns the music off. Fixing how sounds work together in the operating room is a step in the right direction. But it's part of a bigger problem. Doctors know more about the human body than ever, and are better equipped to save your life.
当警报处于危险区时，它会关闭音乐音量。当警报处于危险区时，它会关闭音乐。修复手术室中声音的协作方式是朝着正确方向迈出的一步。但这只是一个更大问题的一部分。医生对人体的了解比以往任何时候都多，也更有能力拯救你的生命。
But still, hospitals are horrible places to get better. That sound designer Joel Beckerman. And he's right, hospitals can be bad for your health because hospitals sound terrible. I think of when I walk into the neuro ICU and I hear the automatic door which opens and closes as people walk by it opens and closes without anyone going in or out.
但即便如此，医院依然是病况好转的糟糕场所。这是声音设计师乔尔·贝克曼说的。他是对的，医院可能对你的健康有害，因为医院听起来太糟糕了。我想起当我走进神经科重症监护室时，我听到自动门随着人们走过而开合，即使没有人进出，它也在开合。
And as I walk in, there's the hubbub of people talking and it might be clinicians, and might be patients' families. I hear the rolling of the big metal cart that houses all the meals for the patients, and it's the wheels rolling on the hardwood floor. Yoko Sen is an electronic musician, researching to the hospitals. When it's quiet, it's about 40 to 50 decibels, but when it's pretty loud, it goes up to easily 60, 70 decibels, sometimes it hit 80 to 90 decibels as well. To give you some perspective, 60 decibels is the volume of an average office. 70 decibels is about as loud as a vacuum cleaner. 80 decibels is as volume of an average office. 70 decibels is about as loud as a vacuum cleaner. 80 decibels is as loud as a garbage disposal.
当我走进去时，人们交谈的喧闹声扑面而来，可能是临床医生，也可能是患者家属。我听到运送病人的大型金属餐车的轮子在硬木地板上滚动的声音。森洋子是一位电子音乐家，她一直在研究医院的声音。安静的时候，大约是40到50分贝，但当声音相当大时，很容易达到60、70分贝，有时甚至会达到80到90分贝。为了给您一些概念，60分贝是普通办公室的音量。70分贝大约和吸尘器一样吵。80分贝是普通办公室的音量。70分贝大约和吸尘器一样吵。80分贝和垃圾处理器一样吵。
And 90 decibels is as loud as a motorcycle passing by. All of this, and you're so-called healing environment. Hospitals can be really loud, but volume isn't the only problem. I hear alarms coming from multiple patient rooms, and I don't know what's wrong with the patients. The alarms are difficult to localize, so I'm not sure which rooms they're coming from. And even when he knows what he's listening for,
90分贝则和摩托车驶过一样吵。所有这些，竟然发生在你所谓的康复环境中。医院可能会非常吵闹，但音量并不是唯一的问题。我听到多个病房传来警报声，却不知道病人出了什么问题。这些警报声很难辨别方向，所以我无法确定它们来自哪个房间。甚至当他知道自己在听什么声音时，
Joe has a hard time figuring out what device is making noise. It could be the IV infusion pump, the epidural pump, the interaortic balloon pump, the dialysis machine, the ventilator. Joel Beckerman has experienced the same thing in hospitals he's worked in. There's a cart monitor that makes 86 different alarms. There's no way that that can be meaningful to anybody.
乔也很难搞清楚到底是哪个设备在发出噪音。可能是静脉输液泵、硬膜外输液泵、主动脉内球囊反搏泵、透析机或呼吸机。乔尔·贝克曼在他工作过的医院里也经历过同样的情况。有一个病床监护仪能发出86种不同的警报。这对于任何人来说都不可能有什么实际意义。
The scary thing is most of these alarms are false alarms. It could be due to a loose connection or a temporary blip in the patient's vital signs, but most of these alarms don't tell you anything useful. Still, they saturate the hospital soundscape. I go home at night, and I still hear the beeping of alarms and the beeping of pulse oxymetry in my head.
可怕的是，这些警报大多是误报。可能是由于连接松动或病人生命体征出现短暂波动，但这些警报大多没有告诉你任何有用的信息。尽管如此，它们还是充斥着医院的声景。我晚上回家时，脑子里依然回响着警报的哔哔声和脉搏血氧仪的哔哔声。
Clinicians are annoyed by lots of alarms, but they are number of physicians The problem with alarm fatigue is that the din of sound which caregivers and learn to ignore means that they also ignore critical alarms and patients die. This is a very very serious problem that needs to be addressed. When things are loud people complain that it's difficult to sleep at night it disturbs their, it disturbs their rest. Noise the environment could cause more anxiety, sense of fear and stress for patients. And visitors as well, I often hear from those parents that when alarms go for, you know, their babies, the first thing that young parents would think is,
临床医生对大量的警报感到厌烦，但医生数量众多。警报疲劳的问题在于，医护人员学会忽略的这种嘈杂噪音，意味着他们也会忽略关键警报，从而导致病人死亡。这是一个非常非常严重的问题，亟待解决。当环境吵闹时，人们会抱怨晚上很难入睡，这扰乱了他们的休息。环境噪音会给病人和访客带来更多的焦虑、恐惧感和压力。还有探视者，我经常听那些父母说，当警报为他们的婴儿响起时，年轻父母首先想到的就是，
oh no, it's my baby going to die, it's very scary. It can lead to neuropsychological side effects such as ICU delirium. ICU delirium is when patients get confused and paranoid because of the exhaustion of staying in a hospital. Sometimes this can lead to hallucinations. Up to 80% of patients in an ICU are thought to experience some form of delirium during their hospital's day. It's the sort of thing that can leave hospital patients with PTSD. I interviewed one person he had his daughter, you know, more than 10 years ago in NICU.
“哦不，我的宝宝会死吗？这太可怕了。”它会导致神经心理学副作用，例如ICU谵妄。ICU谵妄是指患者由于在医院滞留而感到精疲力竭，从而变得困惑和多疑。有时这会导致幻觉。据认为，ICU中高达80%的患者在住院期间都会经历某种形式的谵妄。这种事情会给住院患者留下PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）。我采访过一个人，他的女儿在十多年前住过NICU。
That's the NICU intensive care for infants. And there was this particular alarm sound that kept going off. So even after 10 years, if he hears the sound that's similar to the alarm on television or other places, he still gets this sort of a traumatized reaction. There are long lasting effects on the body, as well as the mind. Noise leads to stress and stress hormones and the body stiffens our blood vessels,
那是新生儿重症监护室。当时有一个特定的警报声一直在响。所以即使过了10年，如果他在电视或其他地方听到类似于那个警报的声音，他仍然会有这种创伤性的反应。它不仅对心灵，而且对身体也会产生持久的影响。噪音会导致压力和应激激素，使我们的血管收缩，
which can increase the risk of heart attack. I often caught this phrase from Florence Nightingale, who said, unnecessary noise is the cruelest absence of care. She wrote that more than 100 years ago, but I'm guessing, 100 years ago there was no alarm fatigue as an issue. Most things in medicine progressed in 100 years, but I feel like when it comes to the quality of our sound environment, it's like a side effect
从而增加心脏病发作的风险。我经常引用南丁格尔的这句话：“不必要的噪音是对护理最残酷的缺失。”她在一个多世纪前就写下了这句话，但我猜，100年前并不存在“警报疲劳”这个问题。在过去的100年里，医学的大多数方面都取得了进步，但我觉得，谈到我们的声音环境质量时，它就像是我们技术进步的一个副作用。
over our technological advancement. So I bet things got louder. Right now, you can't turn alarms softer. You can silence them. But the FDA maintained a database, which found that nearly 600 patients had adverse outcomes, mostly death, from alarm mismanagement. We'll talk about how we can make the sound design of hospital alarms as sophisticated
所以我敢打赌，声音变得越来越大了。现在，你无法将警报声调小。你可以将其静音。但美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）维护的一个数据库显示，有近600名患者因警报管理不善而产生不良后果，其中大部分是死亡。接下来我们将讨论如何让医院警报的声音设计变得像发出警报的医疗设备一样复杂和精准。
and precise as the medical devices that are blaring them out after this. Support for this special two-part series exploring the power of sound to influence our health comes from the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation. The Robert Wood Johnson Foundation is working to build a culture of health that ensures everyone in America has a fair and just opportunity for health and well-being, which includes exploring how our current or future environments will impact daily life. Learn more at rwjf.org. When you think of the design of a patient monitor or any device,
对这个探讨声音影响我们健康的力量的特别两集系列节目的支持，来自于罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会。罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会致力于构建一种健康文化，确保美国每个人都有公平公正的机会获得健康和福祉，这包括探讨我们当前或未来的环境将如何影响日常生活。请访问 rwjf.org 了解更多信息。当你想到患者监护仪或任何设备的设计时，
you think of the visual complexity of the device and the expense of the device. But why is the sound that's generated by this highly engineered, visually attractive, expensive device. So poor. It usually comes out of a very cheap speaker attached to the device. I'd love all the medical device that I'm talking about, to be at least not dissonant, at least in harmony with each other. And that's not that difficult.
你会想到设备的视觉复杂性和设备的成本。但是，为什么这个经过精心设计、视觉上极具吸引力、价格昂贵的设备所产生的声音会如此糟糕呢？它通常来自连接在设备上的非常便宜的扬声器。我希望我所讨论的所有医疗设备至少不要刺耳，至少能彼此和谐。这其实并不难。
As a musician, it's like, can I just tune them at least in harmony with each other, and that's not that difficult. As a musician, it's like, can I just tune them at least? But Yoko isn't the only one taking a musical approach to a Lauren Vadeeg. Joe may be an anesthesiologist, but he's also a professional jazz musician. It's inferiority, isn't it? This is him playing the piano right now. I had been playing the piano since I was five years old,
作为一名音乐家，这就像是：我难道不能至少把它们的音调调得彼此和谐吗？这并不难。作为一名音乐家，这就像是：我难道不能至少把它们的音调调好吗？但洋子并不是唯一一个对警报采取音乐化方法的。乔不仅是一位麻醉医师，他同时也是一位专业的爵士乐音乐家。这是一种劣势，对吧？这是他现在正在弹钢琴。我从五岁起就开始弹钢琴，
so music and medicine was part of my life together for a long time. Right now alarms are loud and annoying but they don't have to be. They just have to be different from all the other sounds in the hospital. Imagine that somebody down the hall were to scream and it's not loud but you can perceive it. We have our attention diverted not because of the volume, but because of the acoustic features of the human screen. There's an acoustic feature called roughness, which has enhanced sensitivity in the amygdala. So we have this reflexive response.
所以音乐和医学很长一段时间以来都是我生活的一部分。目前警报声音又大又烦人，但它们本不必如此。它们只需要区别于医院里的所有其他声音即可。想象一下，如果大厅里的某个人尖叫起来，声音并不大，但你能察觉到。我们的注意力被转移，不是因为音量，而是因为人类尖叫声的声学特征。有一种声学特征叫做“粗糙度”（roughness），它能增强杏仁核的敏感度。因此我们会有这种条件反射式的反应。
This has a surprising implication for our alarm tones. Alarms can be softer than background noise, and you can still perceive them. A lot of the alarms have what's called a flat amplitude envelope. And so if you imagine the emergency broadcast signal that you hear on TV, that's a flat amplitude envelope, and that's an unnatural sound in our environment. The unnatural sound is effective at grabbing our attention, but in a hospital, these unnatural sounds
这对我们的警报音有着令人惊讶的启示。警报声可以比背景噪音更轻，而你依然能够察觉到它们。许多警报都具有所谓的“平坦振幅包络”。所以如果你想象一下你在电视上听到的紧急广播信号，那就是一种平坦的振幅包络，那是我们环境中一种不自然的声音。这种不自然的声音在吸引我们的注意力方面很有效，但在医院里，这些不自然的声音
layer on top of each other, creating a wall of sound that we tune out. They also create a stress response that's harming our minds and bodies. Compare that with what's called a percussive amplitude envelope, which has an exponential decay. So think about it if you're clinking two wine glasses together. That's a sharp upstroke with an exponential decay, so think about if you're clinking to wine glasses together. That's a sharp upstroke with an exponential decay, and that's a sound we have in nature.
层层叠加，形成了一堵我们选择屏蔽的声音之墙。它们还会引发损害我们身心健康的应激反应。将之与所谓的“打击乐振幅包络”进行比较，后者具有指数衰减。所以想象一下，如果你把两个酒杯碰在一起。那是一个急剧上升的起点，随后呈指数衰减。所以想象一下，如果你把两个酒杯碰在一起。那是一个急剧上升的起点，随后呈指数衰减，这是我们在自然界中能听到的一种声音。
By changing the amplitude envelope to something more natural, you can go from this to this. But even this sound doesn't tell you a lot. The alarms need to be more informative. What we are particularly working on is how to contain information in sound, and that is what we call auditory icons. For example, having a loved-dub heartbeat type of sound in an alarm that is indicative of a cardiovascular problem.
通过将振幅包络改变为更自然的声音，你就可以从这种声音变成这种声音。但即使是这种声音也没有告诉你太多信息。警报需要包含更多信息。我们特别致力于研究如何在声音中包含信息，这就是我们所说的“听觉图标”。例如，在警报中加入一种“咚-哒”的心跳声，以此暗示心血管问题。
The result is something that can tell you exactly what's wrong before you enter the room. And that's just the beginning. I don't want to know just when something is bad, I want to know when something is trending towards being bad. I want visual signals that are always in my receptive field, versus a monitor that right now I have to be staring at it. I want vibratoxyl information that is wearable and comfortable,
其结果是，在你进入房间之前，就能准确告诉你哪里出了问题。而这仅仅是个开始。我不仅想知道什么时候情况变糟了，我还想知道什么时候情况正在朝着变糟的趋势发展。我想要视觉信号，它们始终在我的接受视野内，而不是像现在的监护仪那样，我必须一直盯着它看。我想要可穿戴且舒适的触觉信息，
and I want to provide signals that are not so strong that I get fatigue or habituated to it. And I want auditory information that is directed to me when I get auditory information. It's information that can mean something in that I need to act upon it. And we can use the hospital soundscape to do even more. Researchers are finding ways to give a voice to people who have lost theirs.
我希望提供的信号不要太强烈，以免让我感到疲劳或习惯它。当我接收听觉信息时，我希望这些听觉信息是直接针对我的。这些信息是有意义的，意味着我需要采取行动。我们可以利用医院的声景做得更多。研究人员正在寻找方法，为那些失去声音的人赋予声音。
You think of a patient in the ICU when they're non-communicative or in long-term acute care, those patients often get neglected, but they have ways to communicate in a non-traditional sense, for example, through their autonomic nervous system. Patients who can't speak or communicate their feelings are still expressing themselves through their heart rate or their body temperature. So they're communicating but not in a traditional verbal sense. How can we take those physiologic signals, turn them into sound in a way that we can start to ascertain what these patients, what these people are saying.
你可以想想ICU里的患者，当他们无法交流或处于长期急性护理中时，这些患者往往会被忽视，但他们有非传统意义的交流方式，例如通过他们的自主神经系统。那些无法说话或表达自己感受的患者仍然在通过他们的心率或体温来表达自己。所以他们是在交流，但不是通过传统的言语方式。我们如何才能将这些生理信号转化为声音，从而开始弄清楚这些患者、这些人到底在说些什么？
The result is something called biomew music, pioneered by a colleague of Joe's at McGill University in Montreal. Sensors on the patient's body detect vital signs, and that makes the data into sound. Heart rate controls the tempo, temperature determines the notes, and skin sweat drives the melody. The result is actually kind of beautiful. Biomusic is being looked at as a way for non-verbal autistic children to express themselves.
其结果被称为“生物音乐”（biomusic），由乔在蒙特利尔麦吉尔大学的一位同事首创。患者身体上的传感器检测生命体征，并将数据转化为声音。心率控制节奏，体温决定音符，皮肤出汗驱动旋律。其结果其实相当美观。人们正将生物音乐视为非语言自闭症儿童表达自己的一种方式。
Here's a calm state of mind. And here's an anxious one. You don't have to be a medical specialist to hear the difference. Our hope is that we can make it easy to implement throughout the world where you don't have to be at a high-powered academic institution with fancy EEG equipment to make this a reality. Joel Buckerman believes our hospital soundscapes can be improved from an unhealthy and dangerous cacophony to
这里是一个平静的心态。这里是一个焦虑的心态。你不需要成为医学专家就能听出其中的区别。我们的希望是，我们可以使其易于在世界各地实施，你不必身处拥有昂贵脑电图（EEG）设备的高精尖学术机构，也能让这一愿景成为现实。乔尔·贝克曼认为，我们的医院声景可以从不健康且危险的噪声改善为
something more useful and healthy. Imagine you could walk into a room and be able to sift through enormous data sets by sound alone. We actually create an idealized sound scape for what a sonification of data idea might be in a hospital room of the future. Basically, I think is in good shape. Maybe a week we can look at the chart again and make sure it sounds good. You don't need to be a musician, you don't need to be really intensely trained for this. You can determine whether a pitch is higher than another or lower than another if they're pretty far apart.
更有用、更健康的东西。想象一下，你可以走进一个房间，仅凭声音就能筛选庞大的数据集。我们实际上为未来医院病房中的数据声化构想创造了一个理想的声景。基本上，我认为情况很好。也许一周后我们可以再次查看图表，确保它听起来不错。你不需要成为音乐家，你不需要为此接受过高强度的专业训练。如果两个音高相距较远，你就能判断出一个音高是比另一个高还是低。
You can determine whether a sound is rising or a sound is falling. In a very, very short period of time, we can help people understand those differences of all the different key healthcare data points to understand what a patient needs or whether that patient is okay and they can turn their attention elsewhere. When I was in music school, my piano teacher told me, the more you actively listen to jazz and you practice, you're adding colors to your palate. The more I study, the more I practice, the more I listen, I have more colors on my palette. I can create a beautiful painting. And so the reason why
你可以判断声音是在上升还是在下降。在非常非常短的时间内，我们可以帮助人们理解所有不同关键医疗保健数据点的这些差异，从而了解患者需要什么，或者该患者是否安好，然后他们可以把注意力转向别处。当我在音乐学校时，我的钢琴老师告诉我，你越是积极地听爵士乐并练习，你就是在为调色板添加色彩。我学习得越多，练习得越多，听得越多，我的调色板上的色彩就越丰富。我可以创作出一幅美丽的画作。所以这就是为什么
we need to do this is because this adds colors to our palette. And I think it's important from a patient care perspective that we make the most beautiful painting that we can create. that we can create. This special episode of 99% Invisible was produced by Laila Badasen and Dallas Taylor, with help from Sam Sneepley, edited by Chris Burrubay, sound design and mix by Colin Devarnie, music by Sean Real. Thanks also to our guests, Yoko Sen and Joe Sleshinger. Special thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation and man-made music who contributed as executive producers
我们需要这样做，因为这为我们的调色板增添了色彩。我认为从患者护理的角度来看，创作出我们所能创作的最美丽画作非常重要。我们所能创作的。这期特别节目的 99% Invisible 由莱拉·巴达森（Laila Badasen）和达拉斯·泰勒（Dallas Taylor）制作，萨姆·斯尼普利（Sam Sneepley）提供了帮助，克里斯·布鲁贝（Chris Burrubay）剪辑，科林·德瓦尼（Colin Devarnie）负责声音设计和混音，肖恩·里尔（Sean Real）配乐。同时感谢我们的嘉宾森洋子和乔·斯莱辛格。特别感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会以及作为执行制片人并为节目提供声景的人造音乐公司（Man-Made Music）。
and providing the soundscapes in the show. Joel Buckerman, his written a book, it's called The Sonic Boom, How Sound transforms the way we think, feel, and buy, go check it out. You can learn more about these stories and other topics related to Sonic Humanism and sounds affects on our health by visiting info.sonichumanism.com.
乔尔·贝克曼写过一本书，名为《音爆：声音如何改变我们的思维、感觉和购买方式》，快去看看吧。你可以通过访问 info.sonichumanism.com 了解更多关于这些故事以及与声音人本主义和声音对我们健康的影响相关的主题。
wjf.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
rwjf.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。